Halloween can be expensive candy
decorations it all adds up and then
there's hopefully your perfectly fitting
costume so
this ocean is how can you save a little
money get creative still find something
that's you know scary maybe or cute or
just super creative like Candace they
are joining us live from Goodwill this
morning love the hat Candace
thank you good morning to listen John
you probably should have came here and
got your costume and may have fit better
and you may have saved some money so I'm
coming in with the punch you guys
because if you're going creative or
whether you're going traditional you
don't have to break the bank to get a
costume for you and your kiddos and I'm
joined by Goodwill's Morgan Waldron
thank you so much for joining me this
morning tell the folks first of all what
are we wearing yeah so we're having some
fun this morning with you as Hawaiian
Punch and me as a sandwich I like it I
like it very cool I know I know that can
cost maybe 60 bucks or more or more to
get a costume from a traditional costume
shop what is the average price people
are paying and what are some of the
options here yes so our costumes are all
under ten dollars I've heard that right
under 10 bucks this is 4.99 but you want
to accessorize you can be under 10 bucks
and most of these here are under ten
dollars and they're also eco-friendly
and good for the environment when you
shop or used that is really awesome now
I know we're going to be talking a
little bit about the children's costumes
coming up but besides it being just just
be this being five dollars getting the
accessories how much are those yes the
accessories range from a dollar up to
maybe five or ten but if you get some
really big like nice pumpkins it's
definitely more than half the price at
those other retailers okay okay cool I
do see that you have some traditional
costumes here as well show us what you
got yeah like the Ghostbusters it's only
ten dollars you can do the Pink Ladies
in Greece for 5.99 each so you can get a
couple's costume for ten dollars lots of
great finds you never know what you're
gonna find that's why it's so much fun
yes you never know what you're gonna
find good well thank you so much Morgan
for chatting with us this morning and
you guys as I mentioned coming up we're
going to be telling you about the
children's costumes also less than 10
bucks and later on I'm going to be
telling you how coming to Goodwill is
also a good way to give back to the
community but for now live from the
Goodwill off of Eastern Avenue I'm
Candace Charles eight news now all right
thank you punch that's so creative I
didn't to see the boxing glove until the
end like that was like a nice little
last second little right cross all right